all right it is at the top of the hour
here so we're going to get started so
good afternoon everyone
let's try that again
good afternoon everyone perfect you ever
gonna make everyone like what's going on
and there we got to go over there what's
that one you already know what this
means it means this right this is what
we're trying to do with the product that
I'm about to show you and introduce you
to we're going to help you succeed at
the products part and what we're trying
to do at Microsoft is produce some of
the coolest products possible to make
convincing the people easy because if
the products are cool they're all going
to want to use it and inadvertently
they're going to make doing DevOps
easier because they're using the
products that we need them to to enable
continuous integration continuous
delivery infrastructures code so my job
at Microsoft is to travel around the
world talking about DevOps getting
feedback from our customers and then
taking that feedback back to the product
team and said hey we got to make sure it
does this too because it does that more
people will use it that'll make the rest
of this stuff really really easy how do
we do this at Microsoft we want you to
do it continuously we want you to do
continuous integration so for those who
aren't developers continuous integration
is the process by which upon every
commit to a repository the code should
be downloaded compiled tested and
packaged for deployment how many of you
work in a team right now that does not
have continuous integration ok someone
these lying in here right because I've
never once asked that question and no
one raised their hand not one time if if
you aren't that's fantastic if you are
and you're ashamed to raise your hand go
back tomorrow and install it yourself
right we give it to you for free you do
not have to get permission from anyone
on your team because if you implement it
they don't have to know that you
implemented it if your are already
committing to a get repository and I add
CI they won't know that I added it until
I'm the one still working when you break
the build because I know better than to
go get the latest because I know that
you broke the build everyone else on the
team is gonna go get the latest version
of the code and all their builds are
going to be broken and they won't be
able to work so continuous integration
just go back and install it do not ask
for permission to do so and I think
that's true about a lot of the things
that we're going to talk about today
you don't need someone's permission to
go do it when it doesn't cost
anything and it won't impede anyone
else's progress what you're doing is
slowly adding value to your process see
I can do that and CD can do that as well
now it's more than just packaging the
software and deploying it it's about
learning from that code as it's running
in production the definition of DevOps
we harp on the word value a lot
you cannot just assume that you
delivered value you have to be able to
prove that you delivered value and the
way that you do that is by measuring
what's happening in production if I were
to just add a brand new feature and we
look at the telemetry and nobody is
using that feature did I deliver value
no I just pushed random bits to a server
that no one seemed to care about but if
I can actually prove that yes 95% of the
people that visited our website after
deploying that feature started using it
we know definitively that we delivered
value and that's really powerful when
you're doing agile because if you're
doing agile you live by something called
a backlog it's a laundry list of any and
everything that your product owner
believes that your software should do
the goal of the product owners to make
sure that your product backlog is in
priority order so they're moving items
around all we're doing is assuming that
they're right how do we verify that the
product backlog is actually in the
proper order this is the way that you do
that you monitor it while it's running
in production just don't take someone's
word for it because if you're coming
from the waterfall world I can promise
you your product owner thinks everything
on that board is priority number one
they simply do not care what order you
do it in because they're not going to
ship it till you do them all they
completely don't understand what agile
is about agile is about shipping as soon
as there is value and that waterfall
mindset is we don't ship it until all
the features are done so I really don't
care what the priorities of any of this
stuff is we're just going to ship it
when you get to the bottom but actually
monitoring the software as you produce
it will actually help the product owner
determine if it's prioritize right or
not continuous integration leaves to
continuous delivery continuous delivery
leads to continuous monitoring and
learning and that cycles right back to
the start again so this is a circle that
you get on and you never get off once
you kind of have the technology in place
there's another couple other things that
you need as well you need a platform
that is flexible that is powerful and
that
open and we believe that that's a sure
it's definitely flexible right there's
sass I as pass any type of services that
you want from BMS to service we have
that there for you powerful or a matter
of fact in Sweden we're standing up a
datacenter right now we dropped those
things like crazy I remember the first
time I saw Scott talk about how many
data centers were yahar at had we
already had more than Google and AWS
combined and I think we only had like 20
of them right we have more than 50 of
those things now popping up all over the
world so we have the power that you need
basically it's infinite scale and it's
completely open
we run 50% Linux workloads in Azure I
Microsoft company Microsoft runs 50%
Linux workloads in Azure which is just
crazy when you think about it I'm old
enough as I described in the keynote I
remember when Microsoft thought
open-source and Linux were the cancers
of the world and they should be killed
and now here we are the number one
contributor open-source on the planet
and run 50% Linux workloads in our cloud
right so we're not again we're not the
Microsoft that you were you used to know
we're a brand-new Microsoft that is
flexible that is powerful and that is
open to all the type of development that
you're gonna want to be able to do the
way that we enable that for you is the
product team that I was talking about
earlier today they produce five
different services and we're going to go
over each one of these services here
together the first one we talk about is
as your boards we just also announced
that Microsoft build that as your boards
is now in the github marketplace so we
don't care if you're using github as
your source control or our repositories
as your source control you can actually
use Azure boards to do all your planning
you can now upgrade those issues that
you have in github into actual work
items that you can plan track and groom
on your product backlog we also have as
your pipelines I think is the crown
jewel of this suite it has been
integrated with github for a long time
now as NAT Friedman CEO of github likes
to say as your pipelines offers the
single most generous open source
offering on planet Earth if you have a
public repository inside of github we
will give you access to
Mac OS Windows and Linux across 10
concurrent pipelines in unlimited billed
minutes for free right there is no other
CI system that even offers you all three
of them and they definitely don't give
you that much billed time for free and
they definitely don't give you 10
concurrent pipelines to boot so if you
have a public repository in github there
is no reason you should not be using
Azure pipelines to do your build builds
can be defined in yamo they can be
defined visually the whole nine yards we
also started announcing that build that
we now have a unified llamo or what
we're calling multistage amel to where
you can not only define your CI but you
can also announce define your CD in Y
Amal as well a single file that takes
you from commit to production
historically you would have your CI be
one file and potentially your CD be a
separate file if you are lucky enough to
find a system that had seen a llamo for
release at all and now you can actually
do that with a single file using our
multi stage pipeline someone remind me
to show you how to enable that that's
still in preview it is not just gonna be
in your repo you got to go to your
avatar and say show me these preview
features and it will pop up and someone
please remind me to show you how to do
that
that's as your pipelines then we have as
your repos we need it as a repos before
we bought github right we needed to make
sure that our people had a way to store
the source code git has become the most
popular source control system on the
planet so we made sure that we
implemented get inside of Azure DevOps
before get became popular there was
another form called centralized version
control or what we call TF VC which we
still support to this day and there are
times or gets the right answer and
believe it or not people there's time
when it's not alright don't go to get
just because all your friends are going
to get you go to get when it solves a
problem for you and if you're doing a
lot of game development with a lot of
binaries and artwork TF VC is a
fantastic CI Amina's some fantastic
source control system because it handles
binaries really really well we didn't
have to add anything to it because the
do binaries really well then get you got
to add plugins to it but for TFB C you
don't need to do that and we're the only
platform I know that offers you two
different types of source control
centralized or distributed your choice
now the question is well now you do own
github where should I put my code github
or as your pipeline there I has a repos
wherever you want because we do own them
now so this is essentially pick
whichever one feels the best and it
integrates perfectly with all the rest
of the tools on the screen so the choice
is yours you can get with this or you
can get with that it doesn't matter to
us we get all the money anyway okay so
what's next is test plans test plans is
for all the people who raise their hands
this is what I'm going to tell you about
so you can tell all the testers about
who clearly are not in this room right
you're here and you know they exist and
what this allows them to do is create
their test configurations their test
plans track their entire test matrices
and next make sure that the manual test
that they want to run against your code
has a home inside of Azure pipelines I
mean as your DevOps and allows them to
track it against the builds that they
get from Azure pipelines everything on
this screen here integrates with each
other right out of the box it's the
traceability that used to be the crown
jewel of our offering from the time a
person makes an idea to the commitment
to the repository to the CI NCD and the
test cases they all naturally just link
together I can look at a bug failure in
our test plan tell you what build it was
in what work item they were working on
and what lines of code they changed that
actually caused that bug to happen right
that's the beautiful thing here about
using the entire suite and one of the
last things that we just added was Azure
artifacts is anyone ever heard of
artifactory right from jay frog that's
essentially their compete for that
product so to give you some idea what it
is
this is competing with artifactory this
is competing with like HP's test
something or other I forgot what their
product is called this is you're
competing with everybody github get a
get lab bitbucket subversion material
name one of them that's what this is are
competing with pipelines circle CI
Travis Jenkins app fair all that kind of
stuff and this the biggest competitor
for this is JIRA so if you're using JIRA
already you can replace it with boards
all those different things that you're
using chances are there's a tool here
that will actually replace that for you
as well
now you don't have to replace the tools
that you already have we went through a
lot of effort to break these products
apart back when we call the Team
Foundation server we basically
positioned it and market it is as the
one thing that you need rip everything
else that you have out replace it with
TFS and the world will be great well it
would have been great if you were dotnet
on Windows
for your java on linux we could get it
to work for a lot of money and it wasn't
really good when we were done but it
worked right but it was painful so what
we did is he said we got to fix that
part
our customers want parts of it but not
all of it so let's go ahead and break
all five services out and make them work
really well for any language targeting
any platform but out of the box they
need to work really well together
which is exactly what they do but if
you've already have a huge investment in
Jenkins
you don't have to abandon it you can
actually have us pull the artifacts from
Jenkins jobs and deploy them using
release management if you're already
using ansible you can use it you don't
have to switch over to arm or the azure
CLI you can still use ansible or
terraform or whatever infrastructures
code technology you want to use and you
can then interact with the stuff that we
have you can mix mash github and Python
and whatever other soup here another
thing that's really cool is look at this
down here a lot of our customers have a
multi cloud initiative we don't want to
put all our eggs in one basket we need
to make sure that we can run on all the
different clouds and even fell over from
one cloud to another cloud so something
bad happen so obviously we work really
well with Azure the AWS team actually
wrote an extension for Azure pipelines
that allows you to access every resource
in AWS using our pipeline that's just
goes to show you how good our pipeline
is that our competitors are writing the
extensions to make sure that you can use
our tools to deploy their cloud GCP they
have a command line tool and I'll show
you that anything you can do from the
command line
you can do from our system here as well
right so every cloud is accessible now
not only are the cloud successful also
containers mobile phones IOT devices
there was a session today by one of my
peers named Edie Thompson who actually
deployed to a Commodore 64 any language
any platform I've seen our build agent
running on a Raspberry Pi any language
any platform
I can deploy Java just as easy as I can
net just as easy as I can no js' it
simply does not matter the tools don't
know what the languages are nor do the
tools care they're gonna version your
software they're gonna build it for you
and they're gonna deploy it for you any
language you want to any platform you
want including behind your firewall
right everyone thinks that this stuff is
for the cloud but we have a lot of
companies who's like Donovan our
infrastructure lives behind our firewall
and there's never going to be a time
that we're gonna stop that how can I use
a product that lives in the cloud but
deployed in my own prim prim asset that
agent that I just talked about that runs
anywhere can also run on your hardware
behind your firewall in your
organization what you do is then
register that agent with Azure DevOps
out in the cloud and it'll simply pull
it asking it if there's anything for it
to do as soon as there is it'll say
great I'm gonna stay here behind the
firewall
go grab code from this machine copy it
over there to this machine run test on
it and then I'll report the status back
to you later but nothing that I don't
want to be on the internet will ever see
the Internet yet I get all the status
and orchestration that I want on Prem
were in the cloud we can actually deploy
for you either way
now there's some people saying even
that's too much traffic hitting the
cloud Donovan we don't want anything to
leave our organization at that point you
can actually install these products as
your DevOps behind your firewall the
entire infrastructure it's called Azure
dev appserver
it's the same product that we have in
the cloud it's just updated slower we
update what you get in the cloud every
three weeks I got discussed this morning
and what we deploy to you on prim we
update every three months but now you
have complete data sovereignty you're
complete control over your
infrastructure and if you don't want to
be in the cloud you're not forced to be
at all again you can use them
individually but I believe they are
better together this is just a suite of
tools that allow your life to be a lot
easier when you use them so first
question is well Donovan how do I get
started I think this is gonna work
really well for us but I need to know
where to go and get started you just go
to your web browser and you simply go to
Azure Microsoft com or you can go to dev
- sure comm there's lots of different
URLs that'll get you there and you're
gonna see a page like this everyone
listen to the sound of my voice right
now can get started on Azure DevOps for
$0.00 you and the four people sitting
next to you right now can go off and
create a canal and all of you use it for
free and create a start-up and use
everything I'm about to show you for
free all right now when you add the
sixth person
that's when we make all of our money
back right your successful startup now
you had that six person and we're gonna
charge you a whopping six dollars a
month try to make back all the money
we've been giving you for free right
this is a loss leader for us to be
perfectly honest we do not try to make
money on as your DevOps we're just
trying to keep the lights on so that you
deploy into Azure full transparency for
us all roads lead to a sure
and we believe having the best industry
tools in the world are gonna get more
people to use them and more people than
to azure so this stuff is essentially
free for everyone okay so you can go
there another thing I told you to do is
why don't you just go ahead and get
inside of get inside of the github so
you go to the github marketplace and
just type in Azure in the search you're
gonna see these two options here one of
them is for Azure boards and the other
one is for Asher pipelines as your
boards is always free doesn't matter if
it's private or public repository
doesn't matter how big it is or how much
you use it as your boards as always for
free as your pipelines however is not
always for free so let me show you how
that works
so if I go ahead and click on this here
go down to set up a plan at the bottom
you will see if it's private you get all
the stuff that I said Mac OS Windows and
Linux 10 concurrent pipelines and
unlimited billed minutes if you want to
additional pair of little jobs or you
want private repositories we will start
to charge you for those billed minutes
you can also set up your own build agent
which is kinda gets around some of this
stuff because we don't charge you for
the private build ages at least not the
first one okay so I just want to show
you really easy getting started very
simple and once you start creating one
if you're already using what is it
office 365 the account that you're using
there is the same account you're going
to use with your Azure DevOps we're just
simply backed by a ad which means your
organization who has already adopted
owes 365 is already ready to start
adopting this there's no mapping of your
users and no worrying about having two
different logins you basically log into
one you're automatically gonna be logged
in to both of them and we're working
really hard to make sure that when you
log in to github you will automatically
be logged in to what you have inside of
Microsoft as well so that's coming as
well so again getting started very easy
- accom or go to github and search the
marketplace clicking on any of those
links and you can get started for $0.00
I just cannot stress that enough how
many of you are dotnet developers who do
have any
in account so everyone who just raised
their hand you do not count against the
five that you get for free so the four
of you over here can start a startup and
still add five more people for free and
have a team of nine and don't pay a dime
for it if any of the people that you add
also have an MSD in they don't count
either right because with your MSDN
you've already paid for all this stuff
when you're in an organization that does
both Java and.net all your net people
are already paid for it's usually the
Java people that we have to go ahead and
start paying the $6 a month for them to
start using the product all right as
your boards this is our JIRA compete
this is the product that you will use if
you want to do all your agile planning
Kanban boards dashboards the entire nine
what I like about as your boards is that
it actually drives by what we call a
process template a process template are
rules that understand how you write
software for example if you're a scrum
shop you would say words like product
backlog item impediment and you run in
sprints but if you're a pure agile shop
you say user story you want an
iterations and you have issues if you
are a waterfall shop you have
requirements change requests and the
like our tool understands that you can
choose between those three processes and
then we will change the vocabulary and
the menus in the product to match the
words that you should be using in your
daily standup
too often you use a generic type of tool
that doesn't understand how you write
software and it doesn't map really well
to the vocabulary that you use on the
daily basis and they're trying to say
okay I said user story but what does
that map to and the tool because the
tool doesn't use that word we fix all
that stuff for you the words you use
every day or the words you're gonna see
in the product another thing that's
really nice about the product is that
you can actually customize it so if
you're kind of scrum or fall or you're
or you've kind of tightened up the rules
of whatever you're doing in your process
you can actually come in and customize
it I'd highly encourage you don't do
that the reason why is because the
processes are the way that they are
because they're really mature and
they've been that way for a long time
and don't just go in there changing it
because you can make sure that the
change that you're making is necessary
and you're not just bending the rules of
the process yourself that being said we
do allow you to customize them I'll give
you an example of where I customized it
myself
so I always give that
morning but I want people to really
think about the customization ok ours
are becoming really really popular
lately
that's the objectives and key results
it's a planning technique and the thing
is is that none of our templates the
three that I just mentioned have any
understanding of what an objective or a
key result is so what I did is I like
the agile simply quite a lot in our tool
I derived from the agile template and
added the concept of an objective and a
key result as work item types inside
that process so now when you go to the
menu you can actually create an
objective and you can link it to a key
result which is exactly what I need to
do to track my okay ours what's also
really fun about the extensibility here
is we have web hooks that fire at all
different times throughout the lifecycle
of builds and product backlog items and
all your work items and if you're new to
ok our is one of the things that you're
supposed to do is at the end of your
quarter you're supposed to grade your
key result the average grade of all your
key results which is going to be between
0 and 1 will be the grade of the
objective to which they're linked I
didn't want my engineers having to worry
about doing all the math and making sure
that they remembered to update the
objective thanks to the web hooks inside
of azure boards I was able to use an
azure function and you get a million
executions of an azure function a month
for free so essentially I'm never my
team is not that busy so I get this
basically for free and I wrote a Azure
function that gets notified every single
time a key result is updated uses that
information to then go find the
Associated objective averages the scores
of all the linked key results and then
updates automatically the objective for
my team members so all they focus on is
grading their key result then the
backend system takes care of all the
rest
just imagine the flexibility that we've
given you by making sure that all these
events are fired in a way that you can
actually behave and respond to them
inside of azure functions docker
containers anything that can basically
take a web hook you can now use to
extend the functionality inside of azure
boards and inside of pipelines the whole
nine yards so let's go look at what this
how we use this now I don't mind people
taking pictures of a lot of stuff do me
a favor and don't take as many pictures
of what I'm about to show you reason why
is because I'm going to take you inside
of the actual dashboard of
the teams on the azure pipelines you
know and they as your boards team and I
don't want you leaking some of the
features that are about to come out so
this is a special for you to be able to
see how we work but don't get me in
trouble right and then they're people
like hey I didn't know that features
coming Donovan just showed it at in DC
no I didn't I was just trying to be nice
so this is a dashboard one of the cool
things about our dashboards is that they
can be completely customized the data on
this dashboard does not only come from
inside of as your boards or inside of as
your dev ops I have one of my dashboards
where we have application insights for
those who don't know application
insights as a monitoring technology you
can put it inside your application and
then you send the telemetry to Azure
that you can aggregate that telemetry
later it'll tell you things about how
many server errors you have what your
response time is things like that well I
don't want to have to go to the azure
portal to look at that data I want to
come here here I have how many times I
commit code how many builds I'm running
and the last release and thanks to the
widgets I was able to bring in the
information from application insights
and put it on the exact same dashboard
so have this beautiful heads-up display
that says this was the last release and
this is how healthy that release is
right now running in production but from
data that we're getting inside of
application insights I can see who my
teams are I can see what Sprint we're
currently in a manufacturer at the end
of a sprint right now I can see how many
active bugs we have well this is good
last time I showed that these numbers
were a lot worse than this so this is
progress which is good if you scroll
down here some of them will start to
reload asynchronously you can see what
poor request you're participating in you
can see what the velocity of this
particular team is and you can actually
write your own widgets you're gonna hear
me talk about extensibility a lot
because I think it's a really powerful
feature of the of the toolset I don't
even know if I would call it a toolset
this is more like a platform web hooks
on the way out that widget are all
written by us and you can actually write
your own as well we have lots of people
in our marketplace and let me show you
where that marketplace is real quick so
if we to come over here and go to our
marketplace our marketplace is where we
have all these types of extensions and
many of the extensions in the
marketplace add additional widgets to
Azure DevOps so that you can actually
start showing some really cool stuff
here for example or some of the
top featured products many of these
actually have dashboard widget says you
can then add to your dashboard to make
it a much more rich experience for all
your developers who are using the
product these are extremely easy to
write if you know HTML and JavaScript
you can write one of these and the way
that you learn how to do that you just
simply go to Doc's comm and from Doc's
comm you click on Azure DevOps and down
here on the right hand corner you simply
go to discover extensions develop
extensions integrate the application so
this gives you samples of ways that you
can go back in and extend - your devops
to do things it doesn't do
out-of-the-box and trust me it's really
really easy to do I've actually written
several custom tasks and I'm proud of
two of them because they ended up in the
box and what I mean by that is that we
take pull requests on our git repository
because all of our tasks are developed
in the open and github I had a the
docker task was originally written by me
the SSD task was originally written by
me I wasn't willing to wait for the team
I had a demo I had to go do I wrote him
my boss saw them next thing I know
they're in the box right so it's really
an open platform and all I did is I took
some of the ones that were already there
modified them made them a little bit
better and next thing you know they're
being shipped which is really really
cool another thing that I love to play
with is the REST API I I wrote a
PowerShell module just for fun and next
thing I know it was downloaded three
hundred and sixteen thousand times so
it's a big deal and as 26 contributors
and all we're doing is basically
wrapping all the parts of the REST API
that we need to do whatever it is that
we're trying to do and now you can just
download ms what via Steam start playing
with it if you are interested in it I'll
give you one more tidbit here so we'll
just go to the powershell gallery just
come in here and search for vs team and
this is the one that you want so yeah
it's up to three hundred and eighteen
thousand downloads it's an open source
project so you can actually use this
also to learn how do I call that REST
API how do I make Azure devops do a lot
of cool stuff there's a whole library of
code there that you can now leverage to
figure out how I actually do this and
extend it even further so another thing
I want to show you here should we come
back here we can come here and say hey
let's show me the Kanban board the
Kanban board is just what you'd expect
but it's
extremely extensible as well you can
customize it and color code some of the
board tiles here you can control what
your whip limit looks like you'll notice
that some of these are actually a
different color the reason that there
are different colors is because we have
rules in the backend and the rules are
looking at some attribute of that
particular work item it says oh when
this is true you're supposed to be a
different color what's really nice about
that is if something is blocked or
something's priority-one
you can actually have its picture or
color automatically change to make sure
that it doesn't get lost because the
more you use this the harder it gets to
see all the cards it's just the cost of
doing business and what we can also do
here if I scroll back down I can
collapse this one right here and you can
see there's other lanes below it right
customer delight errs which are lower
priority than a DRI DRI this is things
that we're doing for live site
incidences if we have an emergency
inside of azure DevOps
that's clearly the most important thing
that we should be working on to make
sure that the service is still reliable
which is why it's the top lane inside of
our Kanban board here but as you can see
you can customize it you can add
additional ones if you want to and you
get a nice summary when you go ahead and
start to collapse this these numbers
here are called whip they're called whip
stands for work-in-progress the top
number is never supposed to be bigger
than the bottom number so we'll go talk
to the team about that later but it's
nice for you to have an indication of
just how much work you're actually
trying to take on the whole goal of that
is so it makes you get more work done by
forcing you to finish something before
you take something out my next feature
request is going to be if that number is
already the same and you try to drag
something in there it just bounces it
back out until you get some stuff out of
there because right now we just keep
letting you add to it and we just
changed the number but I think we need
to be a little bit more aggressive and
deterministic about how we're gonna do
that I can also go back over here and
look at our feature timeline and our
epoch roadmap if I needed to so these
are ways that I can really suffer that
information another thing that I want to
show you is what our product backlog
looks like as well I have a little
trouble with my internet there we go
so here I'm actually able to start to
visualize what releases because we
basically run in Sprint's here let me
zoom in a little bit and we can see
exactly what releases it along the top
these sprints here that we're using and
when I'm actually going to see certain
things actually drop
get released out into the environment
and what sprint we're currently on and
things like that another thing that I
want to show you here let me expand this
you can see some of the variety of stuff
we have here is if I go to our backlogs
now our backlog is just that laundry
list I talked about before that has
everything in priority order for you I
like having this particular screen up
during my sprint reviews so if you're an
agile or a scrum team you should have a
sprint review at the end of every single
sprint that's where you show your
stakeholders all the cool software that
you develop in the previous sprint it's
a fantastic place for you to go query
feedback from your users to add to your
product backlog so as the scrum master
I'm sitting in the back of the room I
have this screen up and every time
someone blurts out a really cool idea I
just quickly jot it in there and then
later I sit with my product owner and we
adjust the priorities of all the cool
new ideas that I just heard so it's a
great way for you to be able to use the
tool that you're going to be planning in
to go ahead and capture that information
as well if you needed to you can go
ahead and expand some of these items
here because you can see there's
hierarchies where you can actually build
a hierarchy from your epics to your
features features or user stories all
the way down the line and then when you
click on one of these things here you'll
be able to see the anatomy of a
particular work item I like this a lot
better than issues because an issue is
just a blank text box you don't know if
it's a bug or if it's a feature or if
it's an enhancement you don't know what
it is until you sit there and read
everything about it but what we do here
is we actually create different types of
objects this is clearly a task and the
anatomy of a task is different there's
things that I want to know and things
I'm going to ask about a task that I'm
not gonna ask about a bug and I like the
fact that I'm able to identify what it
is and given a particular anatomy about
it as well obviously you can plan out
your sprints you can run queries against
all your work items you can mass edit
these work items inside of Excel if you
want to I remember I felt really bad for
this person so what am i people are
going on vacation so I go into Excel and
I run a career that brings in all of
their tasks then what I did is I changed
the first name to Richard and I just
drug his name down on everything else
right using the power of Excel to make
batch edits and then when I pushed on
published he just started crying because
now he had like 35 new tasks against him
I giggled a little bit cuz I thought it
was awesome but it's like how quickly I
was able to ruin this person's life
while my buddy went off on vacation
if you need to make mass edits you don't
have to use the web interface to do it
you can actually bring it into Excel or
Microsoft Project I kind of frown on
Microsoft Project because they bring
them in there and they create Gantt
charts and Gantt charts are a relic of
waterfall and if you're doing that
you're probably not wanting to use the
tool of the way that we want you to be
using it but it does integrate with
project two if we have people insisting
on you actually using project instead
which hopefully you don't have right now
so again we have the work items
themselves those are the actual entities
that you can actually create and as you
notice here if I pull down this
drop-down there's several different
types this list is longer because we've
gone in and we've customized it to have
additional work item types then you
would normally get out-of-the-box
out-of-the-box again it's much smaller
than that but we run a service that runs
24 by 7 in live site is something that's
really important for us so we had to
customize our process template to fit
the way that we do business here inside
of Microsoft again highly customizable
allows you to do your planning Kanban
boards task boards backlogs everything
that you need to do to be able to
transplant and track your work as your
boards again integrates really well
inside of github you can actually use a
B hash tag and the ID of that particular
item in Azure boards to link it to your
issues inside of github and there will
literally be a link created inside of
github where and you click it takes you
back to Azure boards and then as your
boards you click it it takes you back
over to github so you get that two-way
traceability it also integrates with
your pull request inside of github and
also with all your commits so if in your
commit comment you put a B hash tag in
that ID of a work item inside of as your
boards it will automatically show up as
a link in your commit history also in
your pull request and also with your
issues as well so it's a really nice
tight integration between boards and
with github now let's talk about as your
repos again as your repos predated our
acquisition of github so it was clearly
a necessity for us right now you can
actually choose wherever you want to put
your code if you prefer putting it in
github that's great if you're doing open
source development you should be putting
it in github right even though we
support private projects inside of Azure
repos it's really not the best place for
you to go get that that community
contribution the type of collaboration
that you get the forking capabilities
for open source ions
we believe it's better to be inside of
github now when you're talking about
code that you're never ever going to
open source code that you want to make
sure it's private to me that's a
different discussion because we give you
unlimited private repos here for free if
you're already using it you don't need
to get off of it whatever get up
repository you've already chosen chances
are we can already integrate with it
we have great integrations with
bitbucket we have great integrations
with get Lab github ghe our own and even
any generic git repositories if you can
give us a URL user name and password we
can go and get your repos for you any
way that you like so what I'm gonna do
is I'm again this is one where I'll let
you take pictures of some of the
pipelines but again I'm about to show
you the actual repository aware of this
code that builds as your DevOps lives so
please if you don't mind keep the
pictures and cameras away for a little
bit so we're gonna do now is we're gonna
hop over this is the actual repository
where we're actually building a sure
DevOps every day we do trunk based
development which means all 50 of our
feature teams merge into master every
single day this tool was the first tool
that could ever handle a mega get
repository what I mean by that is the
windows git repository tops around 350
gigabytes it is the largest git
repository on record and get was
unusable slow when we first tried to use
it with Windows a git status command
should take what a couple milliseconds
at most should come back instantly five
minutes to do a git status on the
repository to find out that you didn't
change anything like can you imagine how
what of a waste of time that is right to
go try to do this to clone the
repository was just shy of three hours
it was unusable slow so what did we do
we invented something called the git
virtual file system so if you search for
get virtual file system we invented that
simply so that the windows team could
actually use git like the rest of the
human beings on earth actually use get
then what we did being a good open
source citizen as we open sourced all
the code for GFS and we actually put it
back in there so our competitors at the
time github get lab bitbucket can go all
implement this so that you can start
utilizing really large repositories but
this out-of-the-box ready to rock and
roll
Windows is the biggest now but office is
also on the migration to get and we're
estimating that there repository is
going to top 450 gigabytes and without
gvfs there would be no way in the world
the office team can actually use get on
a daily basis so this stuff scales like
Matt another thing that's really nice is
that you can see it's a great
visualization very fast experience you
see all these branches coming back in
because we use shortlist feature
branches on our team and what we do is
every feature branch has to get merged
through a pull request I'll show you a
little bit of our pull request
experience here as well and what's
really cool about a pull request are the
policies that you can apply to them if
we scroll back up here you can see these
are actually already running some builds
here so this is a pipeline that's
currently in status of someone trying to
merge their code back in and here's the
pull request hash that we just had our
build system is really smart to be able
to determine based on where the code is
coming on from what Bill definition it
needs to run so some of these are
running pull requests some of these are
running CI all based on where the codes
come in so here what you're looking at
is us our experience for a pull request
on the right hand side are all the
policies that we currently have applied
for example people have to run a credit
scan people have to run a build so you
can't check in code and try to merge it
in a master that does not actually build
and if we go ahead and click on that
particular link it'll take us to the
build definition itself we have a really
rich ability for you to see all the
files the comments you can have a
conversation with your developers just
for fun we can do emojis and animated
gifs and all that kind of stuff can be
put in here to kind of ease the burden
of being torn down during a pull request
you can have some fun with it if you
want to so I actually really do like our
pull request experience here I think
it's a fantastic experience you can
obviously do the normal stuff look at
the files that were actually changed
compared the commits that would actually
use verify if there was any conflicts in
there at all so going back over to the
overview if I were to click on Bill
succeeded and this build has to succeed
for a period of time if this pull
request sits there I think it's for nine
hours without getting merged back in we
assume that the code has that migrated
and that bill has to be rerun again to
make sure that your code changes having
diverged too far from what's currently
in the master build so it's not just oh
I passed a build a week ago
let's go merge my codes like no we need
to make sure that your code is still
good so if that build is too old we
won't actually let you in you can also
see here as well
that we had approvers that had to come
in and we can decide designate these
provers by the folder that the code is
in what team that they're on if there's
groups or individuals to make sure that
the right eyes are actually looking at
this before it gets merged back in to
our master branch so let's just go ahead
and take a quick peek at this is this a
little teaser of what we're able to do
with some of our stuff here this is a PR
pool and I think the PR is only running
about 20 yeah it's only running about
27,000 tests and I say only because at
our high point we have some bills that
are running 89,000 tests against your
code before it's allowed to be emerged
back in the master if a single test
fails it stops you get an email saying
guess what you got to go find that
needle in a haystack and find out why
that one test failed and try your pool
request again but even on the fast pull
request you're still traveling to
survive nearly 30,000 unit tests before
your code will actually make it inside
of the master branch
but I don't want to get ahead of myself
there so obviously we have our repos
come along with our commits or pushes
branch information here pull requests
and this one I hear you're not going to
see this metrics and analytics this is
another example of an extension that
we've added that gives us a little bit
more insight into the metrics and the
analysis of the way that our branch has
actually come together because we do so
many of these when you have seven
hundred engineers merging into master
you averaged about 600 pull requests
today that's a lot of data to churn
through so we actually had to write some
additional stuff
another thing before you ask me Donavan
what's this thing down here called
compliance and engineering in one branch
all that stuff is extensions you will
not see that on your account and there's
no way to turn that onto your account
the compliance is coming right so you
will get compliance eventually the other
stuff right now is still in development
speaking of how do you turn on stuff so
that I don't forget to tell you if you
come over here and I actually want to go
to a different account here let me go to
this account that I have full admin
rights over go to preview features here
and this is where you can toggle some of
the features that you might see in a
demo by a Microsoft person that you
don't want like hey why don't I see that
optional my Azure DevOps reason why is
probably hasn't come in here and turned
it on the ability to define your build
and your release as a single yeah memo
file that's this one right here that I
have turned off the reason that I have
it turned off is because they account
that its own right now has a very
specific
demo that I use using the graphical user
interface as the build definition
alright that demo is really well it's
very clear and by turning this on it
changes the whole behavior so I have it
turned off and that's what you can do as
well you can turn it on for different
accounts different projects even
different individuals because if you
scroll up to the top I can say only I
want to see this or I want to apply this
for the entire account all up it's
completely up to you so what I would do
is every three weeks I would just come
and take a quick peek in here because
every three weeks is when you're gonna
see something else pop in here we use
this information here very strategically
because if you turn something on and
then a day or two later turn it back off
that's telemetry for us you clearly did
not like the experience that you had and
sometimes will ask you why are you
turning that off remember in the keynote
I talked about listening to our
customers this is another example of
we're trying to figure out how you
turned it on but now you're turning it
off what did we do wrong give us some
feedback so that we can try to make it
better because what we're looking for is
that 90% of the people that turn on a
feature leave it on that gives us a good
indication that we're on the right track
and then we make it an actual feature
and not something that you turn on
afterwards so here what we're talking
about here is again just talking about
repositories if you're already using a
git repository I wouldn't necessarily
switch who you're currently using if
you're not using it or you're
transitioning from VSS or some other
source control system
I'd give repose a really hard look if
you're not doing open source right
that's the way that I help customers
decide on where their source code should
actually be and as you can see if it
works for Windows it's definitely going
to scale for some of the things that
you're gonna need to do with it as well
now actually I think I clicked too far
oh yeah we were just doing repos now
we're going to talk about the crown
jewel my favorite one this is Azure
pipelines
this is where you're gonna do all your
CI and CD and one of the demos that I'll
do and I actually show you the pipeline
I have a I have a pipeline that's so
sophisticated
that when I go on stage I delete every
resource in my azor subscription before
I do this demo that means
infrastructures code is fired up
everything and when I try to go to the
resources like the websites there's one
called people tracker dot us that I use
i type in people tracker dot us clearly
it doesn't load because I deleted the
website right out of my frickin Azure
subscription I go to a mobile
application that used a web service in
the backend
as its datastore gone app starts closing
all I do to get everything back is push
a button
I simply queue a build and I relax it
deploys all of my infrastructure it even
stands up a new kubernetes cluster who
you got to remember whose IP address is
going to be different than the IP
address that's registered in GoDaddy as
my DNS record so what I do inside of my
pipeline is I query the new IP address
use the REST API at GoDaddy and I update
it as part of my freaking pipeline so
there is no human intervention to
recover from a disaster
you can literally delete everything I
own and I can push a button and get
everything back up and running again
that is the holy grail of DevOps that
yeah disaster recovery is just a
deployment this is just how we deploy
our code all the infrastructures in
there and everything and I'll show you
what that pipeline looks like again
highly extensible you can go in there
write your own tasks for example what I
did is I actually wrote a PowerShell
module for GoDaddy and was able to pull
that PowerShell module down as part of
my build process and then utilize it on
Mac Windows and Linux machines hosted
for me in the cloud another thing that I
like to do is that it's completely open
source so our agent and our task library
is currently in github and you can go
see exactly how we wrote it our agent is
completely cross-platform as I said
before we've had it running on a
Raspberry Pi Mac Windows and Linux on
prim or in the cloud our cloud or
somebody else's so it's extremely
flexible anything that you can do from a
command line and anything that you can
do from a REST API is now full game for
you as part of your pipeline I'm pretty
I haven't met a problem yet that I
haven't been able to solve so I'm going
to ask me Donavan can I do all this
stuff with vb6 like yes all this stuff
will work with vb6
he asked me to prove it it's like fine
whatever let me go prove this for you so
I did you know the hardest part is
installing vb6
it won't install in a modern OS without
crashing multiple times so I wrote an
entire blog post 75% of the blog posts
how to install vb6
in 9 to 2019 once I got it installed the
rest of the stuff just work because I
was just calling command lines at that
point right so I want people to free
their minds and realize that this
platform is amazingly extensible it goes
beyond just CI and also goes to CD
because the engine
platform the underpinnings is exactly
the same so everything I just said is
true about CI
is also true about our CD system what
our CD system does for you is it adds
different concepts concepts of
environments concepts of approvers
concepts of release gates things that
you don't have necessarily in CI we've
now added into our release pipeline but
it's the exact same engine exact same
rules so let me show you how this stuff
looks so let me see how much time I have
because I can get lost in our pipelines
I like them so much so this one right
here is a really cool pipeline because
historically when I had parts of my code
that had to be built on Linux parts of
my code that had to be built on Mac and
parts of my code that had to be built on
Windows I had to create three different
build pipelines sometimes using multiple
tools because if you go inside github
right now and look inside of a public
repository chances are you're gonna find
more than one yema file you're gonna
find an app varium will fall in a Travis
tree animal phone or a circle see IMO
file and another Yama file because
they're trying to get to all the
different platforms Microsoft is the
only person where you can have a single
Yama file and still get to Mac OS
Windows and Linux and what I'm doing
right here in this single build is doing
just that so a set of multiple builds
here at the top I have a portion of my
build that's doing a dotnet core
application and I happen to be building
it on Windows then I scroll down because
this solution actually has a docker
container in it and I build that docker
container on a Linux machine and then
what I do is I upload all that code to a
docker registry which I'll be using as
part of my pipeline after that I come
down here and I'm doing another set of
Windows development here I'm doing my
selenium tests so I can do integration
tests during my pipeline I'm creating an
SSD tea package which is sequel server
data tools so I can actually upgrade my
database schema as part of my pipeline
automatically and I also have a full
framework dotnet web service that's
gonna be deployed inside of app service
all being built on a Windows machine I
didn't stop there then I wrote a xamarin
front-end that allows me to run this
application on iOS and on Android and
that part has to be built on a Mac now I
did not have four different builds I
have a single build running across
multiple languages and multiple
platforms all at the exact same time
when I say the exact same time I mean
when I commit to this repository all
four of those builds
start at the exact same time it's not
one after the other they're all running
in parallel and then at the end they
collect all of the output and hand it
over to our release system so what I can
do here is let me take you to the
summary of what will this looks like and
I also did some other cool stuff in here
like security scanning as well so if I
go to the summary of this particular
builds what I'm gonna be able to see
here let's go ahead and click on this
one it's now I get to see the status of
every one of those different phases what
operating systems they were running on
from the summary I can see what
artifacts were actually produced I can
even see where it went through my
pipeline which I'll show you here in
just a second down below I can see what
code coverage I have that's not too
shabby 54% code coverage I can see that
all my tests actually passed 31 on my
test all succeeding none of them are
flaky and I even went back in and I did
a white source bolt scan to see if any
of the packages of which I depend upon
actually have vulnerabilities in them or
not
I don't want to be the neck equifax I
don't want to take an open-source
package from NPM or nougat add it to my
project and then be vulnerable so what I
had this tool do is actually sit inside
of my build for me analyze all my
packages and then generate a report for
me letting me know if there's something
bad in my pipeline or not my pipeline is
protecting us not only by running tests
but also by running security scans that
make sure that our code is actually
healthy once all this stuff is actually
done if I go back to my summary we can
actually click on this particular
release here and it takes me over now to
our release pipeline this is the
pipeline that took all the things that I
just built and actually deployed it out
for me this first two here are doing
infrastructure as code those two are the
reason that I can delete everything
inside of my Azure subscription and make
sure that it all comes back again
there's certain stuff that needs to be
common for dev QA and prod that I put in
a completely separate resource group
then I then go off and I provision the
infrastructure for my dev environment at
which point I start to deploy some of my
services here let me zoom out just a
little bit so you can see that I'm
actually deploying my web service I'm
deploying my database and I'm even
deploying inside of a kubernetes cluster
using helm that I just put up with a
task before this takes your entire
infrastructure and provisions it for you
when all that is done I come back up
here and I start making sure that my
mobile app is successfully deployed to
all my beta and alpha
testers I'm then also able to take the
xamarin test cloud take my IPA my APK
files upload them to physical devices in
denmark and run actual automated UI
tests against physical devices as part
of my deployment for integration testing
i then also run selenium tests against
the website to verify that my fronting
my back-end my database
my docker container and my mobile apps
are all working the way that i expect
them to and in this process i also reach
out to GoDaddy and say oh by the way
here's the new IP address for the DNS
record that you have to make sure that
all of our customers have a seamless
experience as we recover from a disaster
or as we go ahead and update our new
features for our process and then all I
have to do is rinse and repeat that for
QA and then rinse and repeat that one
more time again for production I can
have approvers come in to this
particular process for me for example
let me go ahead and edit this pipeline
for you so you can see what this looks
like so if I come in and I edit this
particular pipeline I can click on these
icons here and have access to all kinds
of cool stuff for example I can have pre
and post approvers let me scroll down
here by enabling this feature here I now
can put users or individuals or groups
inside of here and say Donovan has to
come in at this point of our deployment
and say it's okay for us to continue or
not so imagine that you have a QA
environment you want your your manual
testers to go inside that environment
and verify that the code works before it
goes into your staging or your
production environments you could
actually put them not at the beginning
of the environment but you can actually
put them also at the end of the
environment so now that it's been
deployed into QA you want to make sure
that they come in here and verify it and
if and only if your QA leads says it's
ok
will the code actually continue its way
into the next environment in an
automated fashion you have complete
control over the movement of your code
now you're thinking out loud but Donovan
we use ServiceNow we need not only human
beings to actually interact with our
approval process we need the ability to
have automated systems interact with it
as well
if you come down here to our release
gates you can actually see you can add
things like ServiceNow to your pipeline
so if you're using ServiceNow in your
organization or a matter of fact any
third-party system that you have to go
through to get approvals done before you
can move your code will actually have
our tool talk to that tool for you so
gone are the days where
you have to manually go do stuff send
emails to each other to get someone in
here to go click the button you just
tell us hey Donovan the items in service
now when that thing goes green come back
over here and start this process back up
for us again we're trying to automate
every possible phase of your deployment
that we can inside of these tasks is
pretty simple you come in let's do
something that's a little bit more fun
with a little bit more tasks here we go
so I'm gonna go ahead and click on this
here and you can see exactly what I'm
doing I'm using resource as your CLI to
do a little bit of resource renaming
here I'm going off and installing helm
I'm running a deployment and then I'm
using the GoDaddy package I talked about
to go update my DNS record based on the
IP address that I just got from my
kubernetes cluster if I need more tasks
here I simply go to our task library as
you can see how small this little thumb
over here is we have hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of tasks right out
of the box all these tasks are written
in open source which means you can go
see how we wrote them and then go back
in and write your own now I doubt very
seriously you need to write any of your
own because if you come over to the
utility tab you'll realize that we can
run any bass script that you already
have written any bat script for the
command line people from the old days
that you've already written run any
arbitrary command on any platform that
you want and we can also go back down
here and we can run PowerShell on Azure
machines or directly on the machines
that you have as well so anywhere that
you want to run any of your command
lines you can actually do it so I'm a
big fan of PowerShell and we actually
have two different ways of running power
so you can run PowerShell in Azure
having all the azure stuff already
authenticated for you or you can just
run it on an arbitrary machine I know by
the way PowerShell runs on Mac Windows
and Linux all right a lot of people
don't realize that we've not only open
sourced it
we also made PowerShell cross-platform
so that you can use the exact same
language everywhere in that task that
says PowerShell is smart enough to
determine what platform it's running on
and make sure dotnet core is on there
and actually execute your exact same
PowerShell the same way no matter where
the code actually is living all right
so another pipeline that I want to show
you here is this one here so people
always ask me so Donovan this all sounds
great but how crazy can I get how big of
a pipeline can I actually build this pie
plan that I'm about to zoom out for and
when i zoom out you can take pictures of
this stuff by the way this is all this
is actually a public project as you can
see anyway what yo team is which is the
name of this project it's a command-line
utility that basically stamps out
pipelines for you and it works on nodejs
java.net core and full framework net it
also works on PowerShell and it also
works on so that's the languages that it
does then you have to look at the target
set it has app service app service with
deployment slots app service running a
docker container a CI kubernetes in your
own private docker host when you do the
math of all those languages against all
those platforms you end up with a
pipeline that looks a little bit like
this so we have five parallel lines and
all these are doing is actually running
integration tests if you scroll all the
way over eventually three hours later
your code will complete completely
tested and the last thing I do is I
automatically publish it to the NPM
gallery for me when I try to do this by
hand I never got through all the testing
I'd eventually get frustrated and give
up and I would just push code to the to
the NPM gallery just hoping that it
actually worked now that I've actually
done this I'm actually able to take
every pull request that I get from the
public run it through this machine and
if it gets to the end I know that code
is bulletproof I think I saw a hand go
up
all right so the question is if I have
PD B or basically debugging symbols that
I also want to deploy for particular
reasons how can I handle that in the
build system you remember I had those
artifacts that I was publishing I can
actually publish both the release
version and the debug version is two
separate packages for the exact same
build what I would do then is in each of
these environments depending on which
one that I wanted to I could pull down
which either artifact that I needed to
with or without symbols so you had the
flexibility of doing both of those a
really good question but what I wanted
to show you here very quickly is just
the potential that we have when it comes
to building really gnarly and
complicated pipelines this thing will
scale to whatever level that you need
okay I only have like five minutes left
so again I could talk your ear off about
pipelines we gave you access again to
macula there's one more thing I want to
show you here that people just don't
quite understand until I show them let
me zoom back in and I'm gonna show you
our tasks our agents that we give you
access to you somebody come in here and
I'm gonna show you what our agents look
like so here as you can see or all the
different agents that we have everything
that starts with the word hosted is just
sitting in the cloud waiting for you and
you'll notice that there's max hosted in
the cloud waiting for you
there's Linux machines waiting for you
and a whole slew of Windows machines and
Linux machines now everything down at
the bottom that says private those are
agents that I stood up myself and I
registered them with the system and I
can then target them from this system no
matter where they're deployed in the
world so this is what gives me access to
Commodore 64's and raspberry PI's and
machines behind my firewall but you
don't even have to install anything to
get to all three platforms if you need
them which is really really nice as well
all right four minutes left so I'm
probably not going to show you test
plans too deeply but test plans allows
you to basically do all of your manual
testing set up your test configuration
set up your test matrices test both web
and Windows clients if you need to and
it allows you to track everything inside
of the tool set the test cases that you
create and the test plans can actually
be associated to the requirements and
your boards so if you actually have a
requirement instead of wondering how
your test team is actually going to be
able to test it they would link their
test cases directly to the requirement
for the developer so in my backlog I
know exactly how they're going to test
it and if you know that ahead of time
you're more likely
develop it to test all the tests that
are actually attached to it if you don't
know how they're gonna test it then
you're gonna go to an assumption that
might not match the assumption of the
developer who's actually gonna be
testing it so I love this integration
between the two of them because I know
ahead of time as a developer what the
manual tests look like and how they're
going to test it and I can develop
towards that giving me a more likelihood
of making it through the QA testing
that's gonna happen on the other side
for the interest of time I'm not going
to show you test plans but I have a
really good video on channel 9 of where
I actually walk you through our test
plan features so you can actually find
that and then the other one is artifacts
this is a pretty boring demo it's a
badass product but it's just a list of
names of packages that I have in their
store now what I've done with add with
artifacts that I think is really
interesting is I've sort of used it as a
dev environment when I was working on
that PowerShell module that runs on Mac
Windows and Linux it always ran really
well on Windows and every once in a
while it would crash on Linux or Mac you
know why so I didn't care about KC I'm
not a Linux person to me the letters the
same if it's coal or case or uppercase
but to Linux it's not the same and what
would happen is people would try to
install it on Mac or Linux and it
wouldn't work so what I started doing is
instead of publishing or write to the
PowerShell gallery as I would first
publish it to our artifact store and
then I would use inside of my deployment
pipeline
I would download it onto a Mac onto a
Windows machine and onto a Linux machine
run all my unit tests again when all my
integration tests again knowing that if
it passes there when I finally publish
it to the PowerShell gallery as my prod
environment everything's gonna work as
expected so not only can you use it to
curate your own list of packages to make
sure that they're safe and that they
don't go off and get things that are
vulnerable you can also use it as almost
like a temporary or a dev environment to
where you want to publish and restore
from to make sure that your code works
the way it's supposed to when it makes
it out into production talking faster
they only have two minutes so there will
not be a demo of that either
again it's literally just a screen of
package names and then finally you saw
these people earlier today one of them
is actually here that's damien brady
he's actually used to work in octopus
deploy so if you have any octopus
questions that's the guy you want to ask
if you have any a I and ml questions
that's the guy you want to ask if you
want to know the best the developer I've
ever met that's Abel wing open source
Linux kubernetes
Jessica Dean sre windows dev ops that's
Steve Moore ASCII so if when you use
this hashtag right here we're all going
to come running
matter of fact a lot of people inside of
Microsoft also are monitoring that
hashtag so that they can help you as
well and then finally again if you
wanted to take a picture of this this is
how you get a hold of me on Twitter I am
Donovan brown and that's a lot of
different shows that we have matter of
fact that one is by that guy over there
named Ian Brady and that's a really
different show than the rest because it
has like problem in a solution whereas
DevOps interviews is just me sitting
around shooting the crap with somebody
who loves DevOps just as much as I do
it's more like a podcast than anything
else and you're more than welcome to get
that as well I'm going to step outside
because I'm out of time and I'll be more
than happy to answer any questions that
you have outside I think I'm the last
speaker so no one should be coming in
here after me but just to make sure that
the room is freedom to being cleaned up
so thank you again for having me here at
in DC hopefully this was helpful Thanks
[Applause]